now
welcome back it is 6 12 this morning it
has been more than a decade in the
making of firefighters of southern
nevada burn foundation
releasing a brand new calendar oh we've
got it right here all the proceeds
go to such a good cause they help the
victims uh both in children their
families burn victims so guys i want to
thank you so much for being here nice
and early we've got allen and sawyer now
you guys are both with las vegas fire
and rescue yes so you're busy downtown
uh tell us the importance first of all
before we get to the fun part the
importance of raising money for the
burnt foundation so we do things year
round uh this there hasn't been a
calendar like you said in over 10 years
i think it's 15 years okay and there's
nothing on the west coast for sure so a
couple of our board members noticed that
there was something lacking and we do
fundraisers throughout the year and this
is just another one to bring more funds
like you said to help out people
throughout the whole year so there was a
need you guys are filling it and i don't
think anyone is going to be disappointed
with this calendar i have looked through
it and um
wowza
in fact we have mr april
right here oh thank you so how was this
experience i mean you got it you have a
full
page i do and let me say i had to
dehydrate myself before that i had to do
get the pump and everything but no the
experience was really good the um the
volunteers with the burn foundation and
photographers who participated all had
great energy about them during the photo
shoots and it was a cool pretty unique
opportunity for the firefighters that
volunteered because we all got to got to
meet each other there was firefighters
from six different departments
throughout the valley who participated
to make this calendar possible and it
was just cool to meet everybody and yeah
it was a positive experience a little
camaraderie and we should mention there
are ladies in the calendar as well so so
you have uh gentlemen and ladies and uh
i believe it it's a fairly big calendar
what sixteenth month so yes so that is
excellent now again all the proceeds
here are gonna benefit the burden
foundation you guys are having a launch
party tomorrow so folks can go and
actually meet you
shake hands maybe take some pictures
pick up a calendar tell me about the
event so it's at abel baker brewery on
main street tomorrow so uh august 4th
from 6 to 8 pm
and anybody that shows up
i think the first 50 get a drink and
then anybody that shows proof that they
bought a calendar also get a drink
ticket oh okay yeah and like you said
you get to hang out with the people in
the calendar you know kind of mingle and
and uh say hi to everybody it's pretty
good time i mean all fun and games you
guys look great obviously but you're
doing great work you're heroes and
you're giving back to the community and
so this is really a win-win and it
sounds like you got to feel fun too
definitely it was it was a great time
so we'll do it again maybe next year you
think for sure i'm pretty sure it was
successful enough that yeah we're gonna
put it on again next year and and sawyer
already said he'll do it again alan what
about you are we gonna get you in the
calendar next year yeah i gotta i gotta
tighten up a little bit but yeah i can
get in there i i i think they probably
look pretty darn good already but i okay
so you just you do some push-ups before
the photo shoot right yeah
that's what that's what the bodybuilders
do right sawyer can run from summerlin
to henderson and that's how he stays so
lean
you know what that's what we need in our
crews who are out there saving and
protecting guys thank you so much for
being on the show this morning uh sherry
i have a calendar it is set up at my
desk already
it's hot in here i guess the weather is
a little hot too yes it is